[music]
Hello, welcome my friends. Today I will
show you a tutorial about cur nodes in
geome geometry nodes. Uh it's a small
node in the volume part of geometry
nodes but but it's very interesting. So
today I will show you how to use it to
make uh this abstract particle effects.
Uh so before we start this tutorial you
can see I use CH GPT to uh show you what
is curl. Uh it's an interesting effect
and it will create uh swirling and
turbulence motion. Uh it can be based on
velocity. Uh it also can be based on
other attribute. You just input one
attribute and you will get get a cur
effect. So you can see here uh this is
what I did. Uh like I made a very simple
uh VDB simulation and based on that
simulation I distribute points here and
make it move and you can see the
geometry system here. It's very simple.
Uh so let's begin our tutorial today. So
let's go to uh blend 5.0 zero and uh we
want we need a cube and this cube is
good.
So we need to just go to geometry nodes
here
and press new. Before we do that, we
need a uh we need a VDB uh simulation.
So we need to import that and and I
prepared one
already. Let's let's let's just find it
here.
here. Ensure to choose uh ensure to add
all the VDB files here and you will get
this. And if we press play, it's like
this. It's just the basic animation.
Very simple. So let's go back to uh the
cube and change the name to particle
and uh
the VDB
reference
and remember to save it uh first. So, so
here,
so first I need to
transform the geometry
uh to the same place as the VDB
simulation through here.
Then I will drag the VDB reference
inside here.
So first we need to create the particle
system.
So I will distribute points uh I will I
want the points inside the geometry. So
I will distribute points inside the
volume but it's not a volume. So I need
to change the mesh to volume.
So we we have this
and I don't want the random effect. I
want a grid. So but for you you can use
the random. So use everything anything
you want. So 0.3 and I think 0.1
just for test
and uh set point radius
to make
to make it more clear to see 0.1
yeah then yeah I can't see anything
inside
but I think I I think it's okay. So, we
have the particles. Then I need to build
a sim uh build the simulation system.
So, as usual, we add a simulation nodes
here. And as usual, we need a set
position here.
So, we will make it move.
Now, I think it's a little bit too much
points for now. And now, I think I will
create a vector.
0.2.
Yeah. Then you can you can see the
volume inside the VDB inside is Yeah.
It's changing.
So this is the particle system.
It's a it's so simple. This is the
particle system.
Okay. We have the particle system. Then
we want to make it move. So we need a a
force. We will get the force from the
VDB. So here uh we can see the VDB here.
And remember to turn to relative.
And first we need to get the attribute
from the VDB.
So we will use this one.
We will get the velocity.
So you can see it has a velocity but
it's not float we change it to vector.
So after we get the uh vector uh get
attribute uh before we use that in
blender uh the attribute is like a
compressed. So we need to to
uncompressed it. So we need a volume uh
we need a node called workized grid.
So we also change it to react connect
here
and after that uh we want we we just
can't uh use it directly.
So
uh so this attribute is still for the
VDB we can't use it in mesh like points
edges and faces. So, so we need a
translator node and then it's got it's
called a sample sample grade. So, it
will turn the turn the volume attribute
into match attribute.
Then, so that's the basic structure. So,
here
uh here is a uh velocity attribute. So,
we will add a curl here.
So here we will turn the velocity into
curl into like
into a turbulent effect.
Then we connect uh this attribute
to the particle system here.
So before we press play and we need to
tweak this uh uh to tweak this force
just make it like usable.
Uh we need to have normalize where
normalize.
Yeah.
And we need a a scale
here.
Maybe change it to 0.1
to make it safe.
And yeah,
so this is
relay it. This is the force.
So let's first first try try it. Press
playing.
uh you will see some points uh yeah the
points is moving inside
so that's very good so it means our
system is is good is right
so we don't want next part we don't want
the outside of
uh outside points we just want the
points uh can move. So
here there is a
is a very important step to store an
attri named the attribute and connect it
from here. We will store the velocity
attribute.
We will copy the velocity
here. We store it velocity
uh and store it as a vector and then we
will use a delete attribute. We just
want to delete outside. The outside
points doesn't have any velocity.
Uh so we will have name attribute here
and we will have velocity
and compare
in this step. I think I use float. I
will turn the vector into float and yeah
if it's uh less than or equal zero it
will be deleted.
So let's press play.
So you will only have these points.
So that's very good. And let's try have
more points. So this system is almost
ready.
Let's have more points here.
And to make it more clear,
no too much.
And let's hide the reference. VB
reference.
Drag it here.
So it will have the points.
If we see it from here, you see that
curve
is pretty beautiful.
So if you make that you can have more
points and you make a uh like a much
better simulation.
uh like my VDB reference is just a a
very simple simulation. You can have a
better one.
And before I end this tutorial, there's
uh two important uh uh two important
parts here. Firstly, the material. So if
you want to render like make it make
this particle colorful, you can use uh
the velocity here. You set uh the
material here and go to shading.
You can have attribute here. So you can
put a velocity here and then you can
ramp the
ramp the velocity.
Then click to base color or anything. So
you you will have a colorful effect.
And uh then another part is
the motion blur. So if you make particle
system in geometry nodes, you will have
no motion blur. So if you want that
motion blur, so I already did this for
you. I stored the velocity. So you
already have the velocity and this
velocity is um much better than the like
basic one inside Blender. You can tweak
this velocity
scale.
So you can make it huge, big, huge, big.
You can make it uh very small and you
can make it into other direction.
Anything you want. So you what you need
to do is just uh turn on motion blur. Uh
I think this yeah here turn on motion
balloon and uh took a little part here
and the most important you can scale it
here you can have a super motion blur uh
in the particle system.
Okay I think this is the whole tutorial
and thanks for watching. If you like my
video please thumbs up or subscribe.
Okay, thank you for watching. Bye-bye.